j'ai rencontré alors pour apprendre fois
en france des arabes les turcs bernois
est pareil de voitures vont se mélanger
tout son quartier
quand j'ai découvert tout ça je n'avais
pas accès à ça en russie
[Musique]
j'arrive aujourd'hui à un âge où j'ai
autant habiter en france qu'en russie
est donc pour moi c'était tout à fait
légitime et logique de faire des vidéos
où je parle de mes deux cultures je
trouve que les clichés qu'il y a en
france sur la russe viennent beaucoup de
des vidéos web qu'on trouve sur les
russes csu staps jean-juste genre watch
ngai jean espaces et tu vas genre le
nombre de trucs de fou qui te proposent
ce bac contrat nous replonge dans de
l'eau glacée fait du surf dans la rue
c'est vrai que certains clichés peuvent
venir de ces vidéos là alors que ces
mecs là c'est juste une minorité du
cookie ce film qui le met sur le web
il faut pas oublier qu'à la base de la
culture russe c'est la musique classique
le ballet et la littérature depuis pas
longtemps j'ai décidé de faire une
chronique sur les artistes russes et
français c'est à dire je présente un peu
d artistes émergents des courants
émergents russes et français aujourd'hui
on va voir la différence entre le rap
français et le russe dans la france et
niveau le tance les mecs qui sont au top
[Musique]
bon aussi même jean le rapport au reste
sur mes danse un peu plus traditionnel
[Musique]
je pense que ça a marché parce que les
français ont été surpris de découvrir
qu'en russie il y à du rap déjà quand je
disais je te fais écouter du rap russe
gens et se foutait de ma gueule quoi
quel moment il ya du rap en russie alors
que rien au monde entier je pense que
les français n'ont pas forcément la
bonne image de la jeunesse russe parce
que si tu vas à saint-pétersbourg à
moscou dans d'autres grandes villes
les jeunes au final on est tous les
mêmes que ce soit dans les sables dans
les choses qu'on écoute c'est c'est très
universel au final et ça que j'en il
montrait donc les deux pays peuvent
complètement s'entendre et souvent les
clichés viennent de l'ignorance moi
j'essaye de faire le pont entre les deux
pays pour les gens puissent circuler au
moins par par le web c'est un pont
virtuel ne soyez pas refroidi par le
fait que les gens ne sourit pas parce
qu'on réussit en fait il ya cette
histoire de carapace qu'il faut casser
ensuite tout le monde est super gentil
les russes ne sourit pas pour rien en
fait ils n'ont pas cette culture de du
sourire d'accueil du sourire de
politesse ils seraient seulement si tu
les a fait rire ou si tu leur as fait
plaisir par exemple et un deuxième
message pour l'équipe de france
les gars lorsque vous voulez rencontrer
l'équipe de russie sur le terrain souple
est alesi tranquille mollo cc du foot
pour qu'on arrive en huitième en moins